[Musica]
io sono laureato in fisica e o come
detto un dottorato in matematica
applicata ma da qualche anno come potete
vedere in questa immagine passo le mie
giornate
circondato da foglie di insalata di
basilico ed di erbe aromatiche in una
vertical farm alle porte di milano
la cosa può sembrare strana ma grazie a
tecnologie sempre più efficaci e
soprattutto facili da usare è diventato
molto comune trovare matematici fisici
ingegneri alle prese con problemi di
agricoltura nel tentativo di usare tutti
i poteri della matematica e del metodo
scientifico per aggiustare un mondo
l'agricoltura che è un terribile bisogno
di innovazione
ma facciamo un passo indietro che cos'è
una vertical farm
quanti di voi qui dentro lo sanno per
favore alzate le mani
123 o madonna mia nessuno
allora evidentemente importante allora
fa piano piano ci arriviamo intanto
facciamo insieme qualche passo indietro
nel tempo e poco nello spazio infatti a
pochi passi da questo cinema qualche
anno fa galileo
ha formulato il metodo scientifico ha
definito la matematica come linguaggio
con cui ha scritto il nostro mondo da
quel momento raccogliere dati e poterli
analizzare ed interpretare
matematicamente ha rivoluzionato ogni
campo in cui questo è stato possibile
inoltre gli ultimi dieci anni hanno
visto un'esplosione
esponenziale di dati in ogni ambito
delle nostre vite ed il metodo
scientifico e un approccio quantitativo
si è quindi infiltrato in ogni ambito
delle nostre vite oggi studiamo il
cervello con la matematica studiavo il
nostro dna studiamo il traffico
studiamo la diffusione di un virus e
valutiamo
la l'efficacia delle politiche di
contenimento
anche il famoso rt che ormai conosciamo
tutti col quale si dava il colore alle
regioni durante la pandemia che per
fortuna sta finendo esce fuori da un
modello matematico e dalla minuziosa
raccolta di dati sul contagio
insomma la matematica sta andando
arrivando un po ovunque
questa cosa questa diffusione di dati ha
dato vita ad una nuova richiestissima
figura quella del data scientist
considerata non da me ma da l'hardware
business review il mestiere più sexy del
mondo il data scientist è una figura
ibrida a metà strada tra un matematico è
un informatico si dice che uno dei venti
su debba saper programmare meglio di un
matematico ma debba conoscere la
matematica amelio di informatico
avendone conosciuti molti posso dirvi
che è vero anche l'opposto ovvero da
santis conoscono la matematica peggior
di matematici e programmano viaggio
degli informatici è una figura ibrida e
non si può avere tutto in linea teorica
ondata scientist può lavorare senza
nessuna conoscenza
specifica del campo ma semplicemente
analizzando i dati sviluppando algoritmi
e analizzando gli ultimi ripercorri tmy
dico un ancora nota in linea teorica
perché
questa come passo le mie giornate con le
mani nelle insalate
anche se gli algoritmi e i dati
sicuramente possono aiutarci
purtroppo da soli non bastano purtroppo
per fortuna ora la domanda che visto che
tutti chiedendo lecitamente ma veramente
serve data scientist per fare le
insalate o per comunque produrre il cibo
che mangiamo
la risposta è si
il motivo lo vedrete le mie spalle
infatti l'agricoltura oggi è
estremamente inefficiente se il 70 per
cento del consumo idrico mondiale
dell'uomo ed a casa dell'agricoltura
questo vuol dire che ogni 10 litri di
acqua consumati dall'uomo 7 sono
dedicati ad attività agricole
il 17 per cento della co2 emessa
per attività agricole e 10 milioni di
ettari tra boschi e foreste spariscono
ogni anno per fare spazio a terreni
agricoli per mettere le cose in
prospettiva
quella del brasile nel 2050 appunto
avremmo bisogno di un terreno agricolo
in più rispetto a quello attuale di
rispetto pari alla superficie del
brasile per soddisfare la domanda di
cibo
mi sembra chiaro quindi che dobbiamo
agire dobbiamo agire in fretta
se non si vuole andare incontro ad una
vera e propria crisi alimentare
questo è il mondo in cui entra il
vertical farming che finalmente dopo
cinque minuti che definisco un mondo
sempre più tecnologico con sempre più
dati in cui però
l'agricoltura fatica a stare al passo
con la crescita demografica o comunque
fatica a farlo in maniera sostenibile
questa è un'immagine della nostra farm
una vertical farm quindi il vertical
farming è una tecnica di coltivazione
indoor ha chiuso che si sviluppa in
verticale da cui il nome vertical
i led dei livelli successivi nei livelli
superiori illuminano
le insalate
dei livelli inferiori ho dimenticato di
dire che la sua particolarità il fatto
che al posto del sole si usano si usano
led per generare stimolare la
fotosintesi delle piante
quelli che vedete nell'immagine sono
tavoli di crescita che scivolano dentro
e fuori i vari livelli dentro con le
piante appena germogliate e fuori quando
questi sono pronte per essere raccolte
rappresenta una delle realtà più
eclatanti novità più eclatante nel mondo
dell'agricoltura
genera un enorme attrazione in campo
scientifico in campo mediatico e anche
crescono le start up che ottengono
finanziamenti importanti ed investitori
frontiera a investirci
noi siamo una realtà piccola e
nonostante questo non abbiamo un ufficio
stampa siamo stati coperti di attenzione
mediatica di tutti i tipi da nell'altro
quei due splendidi a doni che vedrete
raffigurati
dentro cura delle nostre celle di
crescita sono i nostri due fondatori
2000 grandi amici benjamin ii e
pierluigi
immortalati da una importante rivista di
moda che voleva essere interessata alle
nostre attività sembra strano ma anche
la moda che sta interessando al vertical
farming
vi volevo anche rassicurare che di
solito in ufficio sono piuttosto così
loro
vabbè se tutta questa attenzione fa
ovviamente piacere
però genera anche molto rumore
e le e le cose che si leggono sono tante
e spesso sbagliate facciamo un po di
chiarezza
i pro
dall'uso dei led
nasce il fatto che si può produrre dove
si vuole quindi non più in campania non
in terreni agricoli
quindi si può produrre anche
direttamente vicino alla al consumo la
domanda di consumo quindi produzione il
consumo si avvicinano i prodotti sono a
km zero e quindi risparmiamo preziosi
chilometri di trasporto
inoltre risparmio idrico è enorme
abbiamo un sistema di irrigazione a
circuito chiuso per cui ad ogni ciclo di
prodotti di irrigazione tutta l'acqua
che non viene usata dalle piante li
filtra dentro
pronta per i assoluta dal prossimo ciclo
questo è il
risparmio è stimato intorno al 95 per
cento in un mondo in cui l'acqua
scarseggia e soprattutto in paesi dove
c'e ne ha poche dovrete un potere sono
molto rigide
questa è una qualità estremamente
importante
inoltre dal fatto che siamo siamo in un
ambiente chiuso e controllato
possiamo fare a meno di uso di pesticidi
e risparmio di suolo usando chiaramente
la terza dimensione
mi pare evidente insomma il vertical
farming promette di fornire le città con
verdure fresche a km zero senza
pesticidi e promette di farlo come una
tensione dell'acqua
veniamo ai le limitazioni perché da
grandi vantaggi che derivano usare il ed
ovviamente anche tutte le sue
limitazioni infatti ci priviamo della
fonte di energia più [ __ ] del mondo
il sole
il sole è
meraviglioso pulito non emette co2 è
gratis mentre i led vanno come vanno
alimentati con elettricità che spesso
inquinato almeno per il momento sperando
che in un futuro sia più più pulita e
soprattutto costa quindi è in fattibile
economicamente generare tutte quelle
verdure quelle piante che sono alla base
delle nostre diete ad alto contenuto
calorico quindi il vertical farming vi
rassicuro non sostituirà l'agricoltura
non sfamerà il mondo
almeno non nei prossimi anni
immaginate chi di voi sarebbe disposto a
pagare un pomodoro 50 euro solo perché
consuma è affatto consumando meno acqua
probabilmente nessuno allora vi
chiederete perché stai qua a parlarci
del vertical farm da dieci minuti e
perché passi le due giornate da anni a
cercare di ottimizzare e migliorare
questa tecnica e allora vediamole
insieme
infatti i verdi al farmi ha una
proprietà che nessun altra tecnica
possiamo controllare dall'inizio alla
fine tutti i parametri di crescita
della pianta la temperatura della stanza
l'umidità i cicli di irrigazione
possiamo controllare lirica alla
l'intensità luminosa e la lunghezza
d'onda di temple dei led abbiamo
imparato che luce diverse hanno effetti
diversi su diverse piante
questo vuol dire che abbiamo un
controllo assoluto il sole non possiamo
mai spegnerlo né accenderlo noi possiamo
spegnere e accendere il led la
temperatura in campo non si può
abbassare state rialzate d'inverno non
si può interrompere un temporale non si
può dare acqua se non ce n'è noi nel
nostro micromondo possiamo fare tutte
queste cose abbiamo un controllo
assoluto possiamo generare hip hop
condizioni di crescita mai viste
sperando di indurre proprietà nuova
nelle piante chiaramente le possibilità
sono tantissime e navigar le tutte a
difficile ed è qui che entrano in gioco
i dati la matematica
infatti solo raccogliendo tantissimi
dati su tutti gli aspetti della crescita
è possibile capire quali siano i fattori
b fattori importanti quali sia la loro
relazione ed escludere gli altri dagli
esperimenti delle sperimentazioni la
matematica è un faro che ci aiuta a
navigare questo mare di possibilità
convinti di questa cosa abbiamo
costruito un vero e proprio gemello
digitale del nostro impianto
ovvero digital twin si dice in gergo
abbiamo ricostruito la struttura fisica
dell'impianto e per ogni tavolo di
crescita che sia mai uscito dal nostro
impianto produttivo noi sappiamo quanto
pesa quali fossero le specie quali
conosciamo la presenza di eventuali
patogeni abbiamo un rapporto qualità di
qualità fatto dai nostri agronomi
sappiamo qual era il substrato quante
volte è stato indicato quali sono stati
i nutrienti usati
sappiamo qual era la sua altezza
grazie al sensore a iotti abbiamo aiuti
vuol dire internet of things con piccoli
modo dentro che comunicano i dati
wireless abbiamo riempito la farlo senza
di temperatura co2 umidità
inoltre abbiamo costruito la piattaforma
di fenu tipizzazione non invasiva non vi
spaventate fenu tipizzare vuol dire
descrivere non invasiva vuol dire farlo
in maniera non invasivo quindi in un
senso
senza disturbare le piante senza falsare
quindi il risultato di un esperimento
semplicemente per farlo usiamo
telecamere che non toccano quindi mai le
piante seguiamo la crescita della pianta
tramite queste telecamere e diamo in
pasto le immagini a degli algoritmi di
di planning la cosiddetta intelligenza
artificiale che abbiamo addestrato
precedentemente a riconoscere che cos'è
una foglia
riusciamo quindi senza toccare a capire
dove sono le foglie sovrapponendo poi
queste coordinate in pixel diciamo senza
entrare troppo nei dettagli su sensori
di profondità riusciamo poi ricostruire
digitalmente le foglie signore e signori
le foglie digitali
una volta che abbiamo ricostruito da
fare riggi talmente possiamo estrarne
importanti proprietà morfologica quindi
l'altezza l'area telephone l'area la
superficie e altri e altre proprietà
geometriche
questo lo possiamo fare su larga scala
manualmente ritenere il contrario
impossibile perché dovremmo manualmente
misurare con dei livelli non so come
queste cose e soprattutto se ci si
impiegherebbe dei giorni sarebbe
impossibile finiremo per sicuramente
perturbare in qualche modo la crescita
rendendo l'esperimento inutile
inoltre
prendiamo le immagini prendiamo anche
invece siamo le piante con delle
telecamere iperspettrali solamente
perché ci piace vuole fare questo tipo
di immagini perché sono molto belle
queste sono delle
immagini
infrarosso quindi è come la pianta
reagisce un'immagine iperspettrale
racconta una storia molto più ricca
della pianta ci dice come come reagisce
quanto è quanta acqua cioè con quanto a
radiazioni nell'infrarosso eccetera
eccetera se non riuscissimo a imparare a
leggere bene questo tipo di alfabeto
saremmo in grado poi di sostituire
lunghe e costose
analisi di laboratorio semplicemente un
immagine però non voglio annoiarvi con i
dettagli perché il punto che voglio fare
e questo in una vertical farm ed in
generale
anche in agricoltura è possibile
prendere tanti dati le immagini si
aggiungono i dati sulle applicazioni che
si aggiungono tre sul peso che si aggira
sulle sue qualità che si aggiungono sui
dati dei clienti che si aggiu layer lr
layer di dati che fino a pochi anni fa
non era possibile prendere tutti questi
dati noi li prendiamo le centrali siamo
in un unico database in cui vengono
strutturati
messi in relazione
grazie agli sviluppi delle piattaforme
cloud con una connessione a internet
abbiamo un database stabile sicuro dove
i dati non vengono persi e dove sono
pronti ad essere interrogati in
qualunque momento
questo dà vita ad un nuovo tipo di
agricoltura una agricoltura dove data
driven usano con termine inglese
dove di reconditi di sensori da
osservazione umana e gli algoritmi
predittivi generano dati che vengono
rielaborati e matematicamente proprio
come ci ha insegnato galileo che danno
vita a nuove condizioni di crescita che
a loro volta generano
altri dati che già non altre
informazioni e così via in nuove intera
di trazione di questo circolo virtuoso
di ottimizzazione
concludo anche se di cosa dite ce ne
sarebbero tantissime
abbiamo visto che grazie a tanti
progressi in tanti campi diversi
oggi anche in agricoltura è possibile
prendere dati in maniera abbastanza
facile facile
l'agricoltura oggi come non ci sfamerà
nel 2050
sarebbe troppo non sarebbero più boschi
sarebbe troppo inquinante a me abbiamo
bisogno un bisogno tremendo di
innovazione noi pensiamo che i dati
possano avere un ruolo centrale
in questa in questa innovazione in
questa rivoluzione è finalmente possiamo
usare gli algoritmi per con tanto
successo
riescono a consigliarvi il prodotto da
comprare o il video da vedere
all amico da dalla i care noi li
possiamo
questi algoritmi usati per darvi il
messaggio personalizzato fatto apposta
su misura sui vostri gusti
noi li possiamo usare per conoscere le
piante e creargli su misura
una ricetta di ottimizzare la loro
crescita
quindi come sarà il 2050 quale sarà il
ruolo della matematica e dei dati che
stiamo vedendo che il metodo scientifico
che per anni è stato un po snobbato
dalla vita intellettuale messo ai
margini dei curriculum scolastici si sta
prendendo qualche rivincita
e quale fare qual è l'effetto che avrà
questo sulle piante quale saranno le
piante del 2050 quello che sappiamo è
che grazie ai progressi delle
incredibili e anche inquietanti della
genetica abbinati a tutte le condizioni
di crescita finora non sperimentabili
non ipotizzabili che vi ho mostrato oggi
le piante nel 2050 saranno piante nuove
che non conosciamo oggi con nuove
proprietà nuovi gusti e
potrei che useremo in maniera nuova e
diversa
sappiamo quindi che il 2050 traccerà un
anno sarà il 2050 delle piante e la
strada che stiamo percorrendo e fatta di
dati e di progresso scientifico
grazie
[Applauso]